we're all in this together or are we the
Office of National Statistics has looked
at the risk of dying from kovat 19 in
different occupations and there are big
variations it analyzed just under two
and a half thousand death involving
coronavirus in working age people in
England Wales up to April the 20th once
again the stats show men had almost
double the death rate or women 9.9
deaths for every 100,000 compared to 5.2
drill-down into the jobs they did and
you find that deaths for managers
directors and senior officials were
below average 8.4 per 100,000 in men and
just four in women they're more likely
to have work from home during the
lockdown
but those in low skilled occupations had
more social contact and the highest
death rates 21.4 per 6 point 1 in women
some jobs had even higher risks for
every 100,000 taxi drivers there were 36
point 4 deaths for bus drivers it was 26
point for their jobs with lots of
contact with the public for chefs the
death rate was 35 point 9
perhaps because they worked in a
confined space and for security guards
will they have the highest death rates
of all 45.7 and that's hard to explain
some occupations have high exposure to
the virus so death in people working in
social care such as care homes were 23
point 4 / 4 men and 9.6 for women that's
twice as high as health care workers who
may have had better access to PPE and
worked in environments with better
infection control now these statistics
come with a heavy health warning the
numbers are small which increases the
margin of error plus the ons only
adjusted for age not other important
factors like ethnicity location or
underlying health but the report still
adds to the evidence that the burden of
kovat 19 isn't being shared equally
across society